hi everybody and welcome uh thank you
for joining us
i'm stephen pitty
professor of history american studies
and ethnicity race migration here at
yale and director of yale's center for
the study of race indigeneity and
transnational migration
i'm delighted today to host this event
with three terrific artists who have
been fellows this semester at yale's
ritm center they were selected from an
amazing international pool of applicants
and we've been thrilled in recent months
to play a small role in helping them to
advance their work
we're grateful to uh for the ways in
which they've contributed to our campus
community uh over time and excited about
what lies ahead
so we expect this event will run a
little bit more than an hour um i'll
introduce our three artists briefly and
then each of them will share their work
for roughly 10 or 15 minutes
uh fellows i'll send you a direct
message at minute 15 or so just to
remind you to wrap up so please keep
your your eye on the messages
and afterwards uh after they've finished
talking i'll invite the artists to talk
with one another if they'd like to do
that and maybe i'll have a question or
two for them but we're also hoping that
members of the audience will send in
questions via the q a function so if you
send a comment or a question there in
the q a i'll do my best to then share it
with the panelists towards the end of
our time together i want to um thank
our center staff nicole edwards maggie
katz and victoria stonecard
for their hard work in running this
fellows program and so much else and for
making this event happen today
let me now introduce sonia and rodney
and akua quickly and then i'll get out
of the way
sonia e barrett performs composites of
plants
animals elements and people to create
interventions
that presents their objectification and
commodification
she also thinks about how to change
perceptions of phenomena in nature
that are a given
the work seeks to create new questions
where there was a kind of certainty that
has to do with the hegemony of normative
european values
her work unpacks the boundaries between
the determined and the determining with
a focus on race and gender
she makes sculptural works so she can
run her hands along the fissures and
manifest strategies for multiple
compatible existences and mourn
her sculptural practices include
place making with a view to assembling
communities under the threat to climate
to reclaim space as well as instituting
permanently
sonia is a mcdowell fell
and has been recognized by the premier
premier ora prize new york art slant
showcase for sculpture and the neo art
press
she's exhibited by the national gallery
of jamaica 32 degrees east gallery
kampala uganda the heinrich bowl
institute germany the british library
the museum of derby and the kunsthaus
moonwork
her work has been shown at a number of
galleries including the occa california
the ngb cake berlin tate berlin the
format contemporary milan and basil and
the rosenwald
wolf gallery philadelphia
her works have been published
in the international review of african
american art black history 365 journal
kunst forum international protocol
journal the contemporary uh and
platform and british art studies journal
she is a co-initiator of the aipcc in
bavaria thank you sonya
rodney gomez is a poet and urbanist
whose work explores the intersection of
place culture and history in the south
texas borderlands rodney has a
particular interest in latinx poetry
ek phrases and visual poetry his
collections include
arsenal with praise song recipient of
the helen c smith memorial award for
best poetry book from the texas
institute of letters
geographic tongue
winner of the pleiades press visual
poetry series
ceremony of sand
winner of the discovery prize from the
writers league of texas
and citizens of the mausoleum finalist
for the john a robertson award
his work appears in poetry
new england review the gettysburg review
denver quarterly rattle north american
review verse daily poetry daily and
other journals his chat book
mouth-filled knight was awarded the
drinking gourd prize from northwestern
university's poetry and poetics
colloquium he's the recipient of the
editor's prize from the from rhino
magazine the gloria and salud pro pro
church rise the rene arroyo prize and
the orison anthology award
a member of the makondo writers workshop
gomez was the 2020-2021 poet laureate of
mcallen texas and received an academy of
american poets fellowship
serves as advisory editor for south for
flower song press and a board member of
newfound a non-profit publisher that
explores how place shapes identity
imagination and understanding
he works as executive director of
parking and transportation at the
university of texas rio grande valley
and is a certified planner
transportation planner and project
manager thank you for being here rodney
akua naru is a hip-hop artist
poet producer lecturer and activist
who's been called the quote tony
morrison of hip-hop
her body of work like morrison's always
holds black folk at its center a sonic
love letter sprawled across four albums
and countless features
she released her debut album the journey
of flame
followed by a live version in 2012
live and aflame sessions
nero
followed up this release with two more
albums the miners canary 2015 and the
blackest joy 2018.
she's performed hundreds of shows in
more than 50 countries across five
continents with her six piece band
she's recorded with tony allen eric
bennett
angelique kijo tune yards quest love
georgia anne muldrow christian scott
rodriguez
bernard perdi sorry cody chestnut and
war
she has a series of ongoing
collaborations with canadian filmmaker
and photographer gregory colbert
in 2021 she voiced the save the night
commercial for german company
jagermeister
towards a larger vision of empowerment
she's hosted workshops healing circles
lectures and participated on panels that
explore topics such as african
spiritualities in relation to hip-hop
and sexism in the hip-hop industry
she's lectured at many many universities
around the world and has been a fellow
at both harvard and brown universities
she is also the founder and artistic
director of the keeper the first
comprehensive archive focusing on
women's contributions to five decades of
hip-hop music and culture
so with that i thank you for being here
all three of you and i'm going to turn
this over i think to sign it
hello thank you for the introduction
it's just wonderful to be here and in
the company of uh such amazing artists
as well
um
i'm just going to share
on my screen
so um
i'm just going to
touch on
just about three things
um
firstly i hope everyone can see that's
the screen
great um the premise of my work um just
one large or two large installations
i've done and then one work that's in
progress since i've been at yale um
um
to just really start with this
um i really my my work is really all
about interspecies objectification so
i'm really thinking about um how it's a
given that our everyday existence is
like predicated on the depletion of
animal and mineral life on earth
but also um that there are groups of
laborers who are unrecognized and
re-enumerated and essential to the
status quo they're really holding
everything up so to speak
um and in that in those terms i'm
thinking about the history of migration
black and brown peoples caregivers
historical slavery descendants
historical
descendants of historical slaves and
also modern day slavery
um
this is like really the premise of of my
work and
my favorite often comes up with a lot of
um resistance and just some figures here
um about modern day slavery um it's that
it's a real
phenomena
um
the next thing i'd like to share
is um the so basically that modern day
slavery
is really
it's it's it's a very intimate space
in modern day stages handle the food we
put in our mouths while they're laboring
in the farming industry behind large
detail in the sex industry they deal
with our bodily fluid um blood fluid
mucus um in caregiving roles it's a very
intimate confidence often overlooked
um so for me to really think about the
objectification of black and brown
people and people as furniture and if
you think about the chair you're sitting
on now it's very intimate contact it's
holding your entire way um but you
probably didn't even see it when you sat
down
um
this
there's a history of looking at
furniture you know and it's
it's it's not um
many people have looked at financial and
art um and looking at the history of
financial art i discovered there's some
art some furniture has already got like
a live element it's got a line foot in
it
this is their queen and style it's been
revived the most times in europe it's
the most revived silent furniture and in
my practice i started replacing that
furniture with my own body
and discovered that i didn't actually
need a prop um my body looked already
looked like
that kind of line foot so in making that
foot
i could begin to think about
objectification
of my own body and this was a swedish
work i made in response to fanon who's
his quote where he speaks about how
we have to um stop our bluetooth slumber
in the in the first world
and um wake up from a beauty slam in the
first world and respond to the to the
needs of those in the third world and so
this is um
being the bed and getting in the bed i
sawed off the leg of the bed and put my
arm there so that i was the bed and
tried to get into the bed to try and
problematize this idea of splooty
slumber or
um oppression and define this kind of
brown space of being in between those
two so-called worlds
i work with furniture and i keep
thinking about it again and again the
work that i'm doing is
um
to corpse pop
so to expand what what passes for living
what's worth mourning these are american
um table let's 18th century
i'm also trying to think about how can
we mourn um
maybe an ore
as well as a brown body as well as a
tree and a plant everything altogether
and perhaps this is one body and that we
shouldn't think about them as separate
things
i'm thinking about um
violation and the witnessing the
violation as a continuum as a holding
space kevin bales talks about slave
holding not slave owning
i'm asking you to be a detective
and
think about who
what the crime is bloodless crime scene
this is a gentleman's um
smoking chair from a club
um
i'm also trying to strategize
how can we move from objectification and
this is one one way in that we can rest
at the space
of oppression rather than leaving so
this resting this chair articulated
itself we wanted to rest
also we can collect advice
um in collectivizing even if hold the
same um
viewpoint we can disrupt this space of
con
consumption so it used to seat 12 and
now nobody can sit at this chair at this
table
um and it also illustrates the problem
in that there's a kind of holding space
as well and it's like looking into the
balls of maybe a ship or a holding space
i have so much heartache and headache
with this work um the most uh like a key
headache happened after i'd done my last
research in new orleans and i finished
being at a plantation and there was
actually headache tablets in the museum
and i felt oh my god i can't wait to
leave this space i want to i can't wait
to go back to london to to deal just to
get out of this plantation space and
then i realized that's actually crazy
because london is really an epicenter of
um
of all of this um so geography
isn't the next thing i started to tackle
because um
london is seen as separate from new
orleans it's even separate from the
caribbean of africa and so i started to
um
braid those spaces so those maps from
those spaces of triangular spade so this
is london corn road and that's the river
thames here
um this is um new orleans focusing on
congo square and dreadlocked with all
those other places
and again this is a map of
jamaica and then something happened um
in my cane rowing and trying to um
smash these spaces together and belie
the map
um the map um left the page
and this became an installation that i
did at the um
in the raw geographic society
in london and so this is in the map room
and this is actually an intellectual
critique of map making um in many ways
but i haven't got time to talk about
that right now
um i s it started to intervene with the
with the images the artwork existing
artwork in the map room this is a
picture of captain cook with his
captain's log so it's reframed him with
his hand on his log
um
i shredded archival shredded archival
maps from the colonial office to make
this work um it happened in lockdown i
started a map elective as a collective
map making women to work on this
together and together we
claimed a space in to make a new map and
more often almost a more accurate map
which is full of holes which is not
concerned with surface
it's similarly creating space or holding
space was this work which is sky which
is uh which was commissioned by the
black history month in florence um it's
made of um hair so that the hair creates
a new sky the hair is loaned borrowed
bought
um
and the idea was because at that time
there were so many spaces that were on
fire uh all these places were on fire
with indigenous spaces where the
celestial had been reconfigured as white
so in australia in in in on the
continent of africa in the in
in
in um
uh latin america there was places of uh
all these places were on fire
substantial but also in reconfiguring
aspects of blackness for it to become a
space
that's malleable transformative um soft
um but also how can we be of many soils
authentically so the black dispora is
like
a big the pregnant fertile life-giving
cloud the the
the
the water raises in one place and moves
to another and rains down another so
this is really a new
idea of how can we how can we think of
blackness a new symbol of blackness it's
being soft and powerful and malleable in
many places and this work held space for
people to gather under it which was kind
of place making
um it was also response to this mahogany
floor which is so much death for me
um the last thing i want to share with
you is this uh this new series which
happened
um while i was commissioned by tate uh
britain to write an article on hogarth
hogarth does a lot of furniture
performances and this is one of his
whereby this and
pair is they they're both unfaithful and
so this chair on its back is kind of
echoing the the sexual exploits of
this unfaithful pair but he himself um
depicted himself in a chair and on my
commentary in in the tate i i noticed
that you know this is a this is a
mahogany chair which means that it's
actually
grown in um the caribbean and shipped in
hot in
in in the same ships that black and
brown bodies were
used to move people
this
uh chair i reconfigured um
just subtle reconfigurations this is
actually with my in my with my
fellowship i was able to purchase an
actual chair from the time
so you can see these are very similar if
you look at this chair
and so they're almost the same
and so there's been a couple of changes
made to this chair to try and point out
the fact of the woman in the in the
chair which which was very controversial
thing to point out because this is work
that supports it firstly i removed the
pad
so now this she's standing this this
figure of the woman for me and she's
standing on a rail but she was she looks
more precarious but she was always
precarious because the pad was not for
her it was for servicing someone else's
comfort
um there on the top there are um
there were these two called scrolls but
i i felt that they were really actually
nipples and that they were available to
anyone who wanted to move the chair so i
just took them off here and put them on
the body of the chair
um the chair is
not naked these are the beads that would
signify that this woman is in a in a
committed relationship and so she's
actually fully clothed she's actually on
a pedestal the pedestal is in here so
what i a lot of work before i was trying
to close the legs of these available
chairs but then i realized in this piece
um she's actually her legs are here so
there's a thing about losing legs
finding new legs
um also that she has a scallop um
which is ingrained on her chest which
references another
goddess-like figure which is another
thing i can't go into the moment
um this is another work that emerged
from this series and it's um
what if oppression is like a dress that
we could take off
um but this body is still there it's not
really a dress so this is the structure
of
of objectification here it's actually a
men's
trouser um
hanger
and then i um was able to purchase the
whole set and really have a have like
explored this and this
last um work here
how to actualize
this chair is the car for chair so she's
actually able to reach behind herself
to reach out to another woman who's
flipped herself so that this thing that
removes them
is
is no longer blocking her to support the
other one this woman is actualized
herself but by borrowing someone else's
arms so
someone else has doesn't have any arms
this woman's arms are folded so all this
is a meditation very much along the
lines of andre lord and sister outsider
how can we help each other to to
articulate
um
ourselves and and to receive really
release ourselves from service and all
the pads all the sitting pads are gone
um there she is reaching out to another
person and what was left was this
devastation this landscape of all the
stumps which really reminded me of the
kind of clearing that happened in the
forest where these mahogany trees were
actually
cleared the first time to even make the
chairs where the people were moved in
the same ships so this is this mashing
of race and
environment and my final piece that i'm
showing is this um this is uh
just the back of the same chair um
removing the plinth so in the time when
we're thinking about um de-platforming
um
white men on statues what would it mean
for us to
leave there are platforms or to the
platform that we're on
where would we go
so basically just um thanks that's the
whole presentation um thanks to all
all these people
who have supported my work um especially
this iteration which has been more
expansive than i've been ever been able
to do before
and um
yes and those are my photography credits
thank you
amazing thank you so much sonia
thank you thank you and rodney i want to
turn it over to you
uh thank you uh steven that was amazing
uh sonia i'm so honored to be a fellow
along with these wonderful wonderful
artists
um
my fellowship project uh has been
focused on creating a new poetry
uh collection
using traditional
creation of traditional poems as well as
visual
poems lyric essays and the like
and i've
really been thinking lately a lot about
historical violence along the u.s texas
borderlands
uh and how that
specifically violence directed against
mexicans and
mexican americans how that
has sort of shaped
a lot of our built environment that as
steven mentioned i'm an urban planner
and so i think a lot about
how urban space is how the built
environment is is structured and shaped
uh by historical forces
um
and you know by uh different mechanisms
of power
and so
i've been thinking a lot about violence
um
[Music]
in in uh you know historically how how
has that resulted in the way that we
move and
uh we we live inside these spaces that
we call cities and also rural spaces as
well
especially along the border
um i was particularly interested in this
this historical episode called la
matanza which was basically a period of
state-sanctioned violence in the late
1800s early 1900s
against mexicans and mexican americans
the texas state rangers
for instance
carried on this long campaign of
murdering
um you know
mexicans that they either charged with
fictitious crimes or
simply killed uh out of
um you know out of spite or out of hate
uh and it tore families apart um
really uh did a lot to
undermine the influence and the power of
mexicans who had established themselves
uh in the lower grand valley and other
places along the border
so i've been thinking about that and
then um thinking also about
you know the the fact of migration as
well and
um how we
as a nation
you know treat
those who are either refugees or
migrants
moving you know across the across the
border to the u.s
from other places whether it's mexico or
latin america or wherever
uh and so i've been sort of reading on
that a lot and i've been um creating
these uh different poems that sort of
take that as
as
you know all of that as background to
inform the poems
of course this is a scholarship this is
poetry and so
um
what i'll read is not uh or doesn't
necessarily have a connection to
uh
that's my toddler
um doesn't necessarily have a connection
to
real historical episodes or isn't
you know it's not journalism or anything
like that but it is informed by all of
that research so i'm going to read a
series of poems from
works in progress from the manuscript
in this first one and i don't like to
preface my poems so i'm just going to
read them you know
one after the other
after giving the title
so this first one is called
[Music]
the desert cold a person by weight could
be mesquite in its fully flowered state
where they're felled or fastened the
sapling to stake
whether used for its limbs easy noose
the body gives its full freight to the
soil and the soil takes it through gap
teeth
two potato sacks of buffalo head nickels
half again a pound of salt which must
have ringed the neck like an earthly
halo just before a final breath
too little body for the pale sap of milk
inside
enough to carve a sash of skin against a
spidery bush
claiming back what it gave when a nearby
star last flared
a lake of ash what the sun will do
connective to soften and structure an
animal
to grieve the animal's absence as a
wreath grieves polished pine
nothing or air without mass
most invisible thrust
that thing which in the desert cold is
least missed and by its lack of heft
last to go
a man is murdered who wanders a bird
where we lose the umbilicus
encounter animus anatomical map peppered
with black lakes where our organ should
be
where we pray never to sputter
run from little conquistadores
highways or moats or walls
a man is murdered who wanders a bird
where we learn cheekbones or destiny
designate official boundaries for dying
bloom the prison population and
imprisoned populations
oil into anonymity or call unwanted
attention to our temperature
where we receptacle into bruised
buildings
disown this or that synonym for
communion
where we embarrass ourselves with a
nation
stake flags into fields already claimed
and call it density
where we attribute pestilence mark
ourselves endangered where we are
surveilled
deterministic zip codes
where finches will not eat a single seed
subdivided parcels for garages and
private wailing
where a cleansing rain is perpetually
postponed
where the accused after baptism are
accepted for justice
where the justice is placed in a vault
for later opening
for the world burns before the opening
house
we came into the house and the house
came into us
it was a georgian and outside there had
been a plantation and later a field
where mexicans held their waste until
they were sprayed with pesticides and
swindled out of their wages it was a
haunted house
we took it from our ancestors we filled
it with freshly painted gables and
columns we knocked out walls and made
the interior habitable by the market
standards and the standards of trust
funds drawn for the renault-like deer
sipping lake water we knew murder was
laid into the house the same as floors
as ceilings as the quiet mold of the
larder
we knew that if the many voices buried
inside the house got too loud we could
run annihilate the shape of another
house and make it our own
we could do this indefinitely house to
house fixture by fixture and this is why
we are said to be fearful of death
because we know we can never leave a
piece of ourselves behind
house
a patchwork tin wall a poisoned water
table a house without gates is still a
house
you take another house taken by the bank
and you strip it as you strip the bark
from pine and you squeeze another house
out of it the drywall and bathtub even
the suspect fume you feed the husk out
of its shape you clone the shell's
dearest parts and leave
a house without peak is still a house
without granite a house that sways and
gusts and leaks a thunderhead
you sleep bare boned on the floor
gulp a houseful of mold still a house
the house kills anyone who lives there
it is no different than a house with so
many rooms you hope death will never
find you
the heart is a mock metronome
the average life expen expectancy of a
is five years less the heart is a mock
metronome
it was the romans who gave the name
lacuna to lack
nights with missing moons
a cleft in memory scarcity of affordable
housing
the difference between visiting mars and
taking out a loan to pay for kidneys
the power and how a fist held up to the
sky can blot out a circling vulture
the same hand if held out for alms in a
glass office is considered assault
the average wealth of a
is purely rhetorical
the kind of wound that forecloses suture
fireworks engulf little crimes
to toddlers a lemon is a moon
small enough to be held the average
waiting time for a new heart in a public
hospital is three years
this is a lie as there are no second
hand hearts without crime
the actual waiting time for a new lung
is disharmony
advice eat right exercise
try not to worry over a lack of agency
a valued meals ensorcement
what transmogrifies
pews a candle lit by a saints uvula
a broken tambourine its symbols infused
with the leftover zeal of a more
gullible generation
the average years uh
is incarcerated is identical to the
number of years it takes to build a
two-story house with a gable
a garden's capillary sprinklers
a backyard a backyard grove filled with
bright yellow lemons
colonial paneling
i think of a thumbprint
permanently impressed on a threshold's
neck
the number of invisible hands used to
coax ornament out of pine
in a house full of beveled doors asked
who designed the doors and who awakened
the wood
only a butcher knows if bones had a good
body
who ate in this room
who was allowed to sit and who stood at
the window
every nail in the kitchen had a driver
every blow of the hammer was a rain
check
who welded the lock afraid my presence
could deconstruct the frame
pulverized brick i could never afford
into its constituent weak forces
the bathtub is innocent
the real drowning was done in the deed
and i think i will read
one more
we become animals or grow out of them
on a trail coyotes used to smuggle
migrants we found a mesquite tree
and underwear hanging like crumpled maps
on its sharp branches
because we knew who had put it there and
why
a wire of fear shook through our joints
after some time my friend who now has a
daughter said i wonder how many other
things we could hang from this tree
thank you
thank you so much
um
yes yes yo um
so
first i want to start by saying like
what i try to do right
for me language is the most important
thing
i'm always
looking at
ways to language
in ways that further my cause
what can i do with language
how can i
um
write in a way that expands the
possibilities for language within the
hip-hop context
because when you listen to rap
um lyrics um
uh or when we think of hip-hop i mean
i think
so many of us have been so miseducated
right there's this is a science this is
um
uh for us to sit and um
and
you know uh cast this forth right
you're thinking about meter uh it's
metric there's rhyme scheme there's a
poetic device that the that the the
artist employs alliteration for
ascendants
you have to do all of that
i mean
you create these rules for yourself
depending on your style as a writer
and you have to obviously abide by them
and tell a story at the same time it's
not easy
it's not easy
um
so when you hear people like nas um who
you know is an absolutely brilliant
storyteller if you listen to hip hop or
black thought from the roots for example
who's a brilliant story teller or if you
listen to a woman artist from lovely new
haven connecticut called the cool naru
she's a brilliant storyteller so they
say as well
um i'm i'm interested in
trying to tell the perfect story i'm not
sure if it's possible but
um i want to tell that story
uh in the midst of all these other
things
that that you have to obey
if you call it hip-hop
so
um
once upon a time i wrote this story
and um i'm gonna try to uh you know pay
attention to the time and get through
this um i would normally put a beat on
for y'all and just rock just to say that
i did it over zoom and just hit y'all
with the real concert so ill
but that's not gonna work because the
time the lat it might be a lag and also
i want you to really hear the words like
if you forget everything please remember
the words um
because i thought it was important
enough to write it so in the chorus i
say it came through sweat but we made it
we're here the chorus is sung in uganda
three persons i'm gonna try to do it
quick so stick with me so that you can
hear me so i can say this all this other
stuff um but i say i said this in the
first verse i said and i'm gonna just
pull this out just to give you an
impression
now in the dark when the night's wild
you could hear her cry couldn't pee
inside she round back near the outhouse
dignified tears strengthen her pride
[ __ ] what they talking about skin like
jesus feet burning the fire heroin cloud
she bake a mean pie sweet potato wild
polish silverware stitch to hammer miss
phyllis gowns
keep the sheets white high heat over a
beach towel on her feet for hours
breastfeed shh
the baby sleep now
she keeps she keep her head bowed
trained to lower her gay smile when
called though was never her name child
granddaughter other slave made since the
days of the big house flat hand under
the serpent trade now when they sit down
retreat to the corner she grinned become
smaller watching the world of invisible
men and shrink more
learn to disappear behind yes mans and
blank stares here [ __ ] falling from
thin lips land intense air
it came through sweat but we made it
we're here
when she alone she say her name just to
hear it called answer herself in third
person roccoletta moss
miss hattie made heinz with a y from a
long line of root workers lord mother of
four they across town with their uncle
roy
can't visit but twice a month when she
leave him the way the baby boy cried
till he passed out dash to block the
front door grab her apron try to hold on
for just a moment more a plea for a
place in their arms mama got a sweet
floors she hear her heart break loud as
her screams down the corridor shards
glass cut deep horn like a repeated
chorus y'all when the bills do was never
enough she peed when phyllis lost a ring
on the floor yup sent her daughter and
appointed that morning head to school up
north organized the search party though
it never turned up low but bubba shoes
laws same size as hattie middle boy
kicks always a few eggs short of a
certain moist it came through sweat but
we made it we're here
she smiled but she don't mean it master
of all secrets all cni from the blind
spot is their weakness know how to grind
glass make it past all this seasoning
rumors of witchcraft she laughed with
all teeth in herbs for every task for
murder the high fever who heard it when
she grabbed and raped her that evening
he strangled till she shake fingers
breaking heart breathing away from the
staircase same hand stroke fill his face
while sleeping she said she cleaned
these crackers porch thursdays quarter
before kids know to walk by but never
wave not from the yard make sure that
clothes need pants press wool please
spray starch that hardly skin half sweat
have vaseline
over here mrs bragg to her people laugh
till she cries say her made loyal and
meek trustworthy before [ __ ] negro
color girl why last may when her husband
died sudden out the blue what's her name
consulted through the time it came
through sweat
but we made it
we're here
for me as i said like i'm interested in
telling
stories um
i want to tell the perfect story i'm not
sure if it's possible um
but you know like 50 cent said he's
going to get rich while die trying
and i'ma just die trying
to tell that perfect story
um
so
um from like at this point right like
i've been touring and producing
performing globally like archiving
um and as i think about my artistry you
know for me i'm interested in language
text and how text can be placed in
conversation with music and movement and
choreographed dance and um and attached
to bodies uh and how those bodies could
help assist in the animation of my story
and so that's what kind of led me to
theater
um
and so but before i go into that i want
to say that uh so dr tricia rose
published a book called long intel in
2003
and this was for me at the time the
first time that i had read
a compilation of um
of black women's interior lives so it
was an oral history she spoke to women
across the country black women and told
these stories um
and
it was uh i think what 21 women three
chapters three through the fire guard at
heart and something like always
something left to love
you have to um keep in mind that this is
before social media before the hashtag
like uh black woman magic before me too
and time's up
um i mean it was risky um and i was so
struck by these stories that you know
talked about you know black women's
lives
um trauma and
loss but also uh resilience and power
joy motherhood uh friendship of course
sex sexuality trauma
um
it was very heavy
and at some point i got lucky enough to
meet tricia rose and we actually became
friends and i had always said to her
like i understand you know black noise
is popping
i mean it's it was an amazing read it's
done wonderful things for the field but
longing to tell was that
um was the one that really spoke to me
and then you know as i'm thinking about
ways to expand as an artist and as
i said like language
um movement
dance and all those things i thought why
not adapt this
um and so right now i'm working on a
project
which i call
a ghetto libretto
right
ghetto for the ways in which uh for our
original sort of understanding of the
word as um
you know
um for what's uh confined a confined
place for outsiders a libretto
um you know musical theater so it's
texas rap lyrics it's poetry but i
couldn't just say a play and i was
working on and this is still sort of
like a working concept but i needed a
way to language it so that i wasn't
saying a play and then i had to give you
this whole long skill so that you could
understand what the thing really is
um
[Music]
and so right now like um i'm working on
you know a stage adaptation um just um
so this is like
um it's
divided obviously into 3x just like the
book is three chapters i basically
distilled the 21 um these 21 um the 21
women's uh
uh women in her book into six characters
um and these stories illustrate themes
of of love and laws betrayal commitment
uh parrot child bonds domestic violence
sexual abuse racial terror sexual
identity pleasure addiction community
friendship childbirth death love
um
[Music]
and of course for me i'm not really
interested in just a mere retelling of
these stories but
i'm also interested in magic
so
that's you know because i don't want to
re-traumatize my audience
you know so it's like you come in and
there's something else for example
there's a a moment in which there's a
baby that strangled to death
but actually the baby has agency and so
the baby then chooses to die and the
baby can now manipulate circumstances in
the real world
so that way there's like a buffer and
you don't just leave you know um
shook
um
[Music]
and so
it's kind of like um you know
um i want you to think about
it's kind of like for color girls meets
um
hold on because i wrote it out because i
thought about it today and i thought it
was hilarious let me see what y'all
don't think come on
it was like when the color girls meets
jasmine sullivan's hotels meets the
black holiness church meets the greek
chorus
plus a little alvin ailey twist
you know in 2022 2023 so
um
so i guess i'll keep it at that um so
that i don't go over time
thank you so much
um
wow i mean this has been incredible
listening to all all of you all three of
you and um of course i didn't know what
you were going to say
exactly what you were going to talk
about but i did want to take the chance
um to try to start engaging a
conversation and asking you if you're
interested in engaging one another so as
you were thinking i was
trying to think of ways to um
you know to to prompt conversation and
facilitate conversation here and um
there are probably ways that i'm not
imagining that you all the three of you
may be thinking about already
but i have a few um in mind and one of
them
was just to see if anybody wanted to
think together
about um
about the idea of being a storyteller
and the way that i could uh talked about
it but also sonia you you kind of
referenced the detective in your work um
and rodney i'm not sure how you would
think about a kind of figurative
character or uh
an agential figure of the sort like a
storyteller or a detective i'm not sure
i heard anything
similar in what you were saying but
maybe just to kind of throw back at you
a reminder of what sonia was saying
about
um
uh about the detective i think you
talked about a detective of the of the
bloodless crime scene so if i if i if i
got that correctly and um you talked
about your interest in
telling the perfect story and seeing
that as
sort of a part of the mandate or the
charge that you have um
so let me just
put that out there for the three of you
and see if any of you want to take any
of that up um
having listened to one another
i'm happy to jump in i think
um
it's so interesting that um the stories
i mean of course with rodney and
like poetry is like always exploding
like multiple meanings of spaces and you
know i mean
in a curious uh
rap there's so much
explosion of meaning as well
so i think it's really interesting this
kind of um vibration these vibrating
spaces that are resonant with multiple
meanings
um
as far as storytelling i mean i came i
went to um
literary fiction because it seemed to be
like a really interesting um lens to
look at all the bodies um in my work
because um literally um
the crime
genre really happened after really
exploded in britain after world war
after the world war and it became very
popular to think about to be and the
reason was because there were so many
bodies after the war um
and so many it wasn't clear who who had
committed the crime exactly and we
didn't know where all these people were
we just knew they were missing and
actually gone so it was really really
cathartic for people to like do uh to
read crime fiction because you know in
the beginning there's this unknown body
there are these um unknown um we don't
know who did it we don't know who's dead
we don't know how it happened but by the
end of the story we know all those
things
so um in
in this bloodless crime scene that i'm
that i'm making i feel like i'm asking
you to kind of like have a hunch about
who done it and also providing the body
for catharsis you know like a lack of a
body is like a lack of agreeable body
which is what the state of the geospora
is right now um it's like it's
psychologically problematic so i'm
providing those google bodies and i'm
putting them in the homes of
multi-generational wealth well no one
will let me do that but those furniture
comes from those spaces um
and
intervening in them
and i think um um
you know it's also kind of trickster in
that you're trying to refuse the binary
in a discourse so um it's a very
kristavian so you you don't have to just
like go to roger you also have a hunch
that you follow and to work out which
way to go so in many ways um um
that's the kind of story that i'm
interested in that um that that literary
a literary lens and and rather than i
mean a courier also said something about
how she didn't she doesn't want to
re-traumatize
she said agree i don't want to reach
formalize my people and this is
something that i really feel very
sensitive to and it's also stopped my
making at one point when i was just
worried all these bodies like you know
am i just re-traumatizing but no i'm
trying to trying to get to another space
of like
catharsis the kind of catharsis that you
have after you've read that for me
perfect story was that who done it like
you know when you have everything
resolved at the end
um yeah
so
can i just say that as you were talking
i'm also reminded that some of the best
detective stories the best crime
fiction actually also raises questions
about what the crime is after all one
thinks that they know what the crime was
but the best in the genre actually
exposes crimes that are far deeper and
far bigger that might be revealed on the
first pages and i mean to me sonia your
work
also does that at least for me
uh it raises it forces questions and
raises deeper analysis than one might
think that they're going to be involved
in
right away that's that's so interesting
because i i noted down um from rodney um
um he said uh the bathtub is innocent
the real drowning is done in the deed
and so there is another kind of crime
space right next right there where um i
think that's you know like the murder in
the bathtub is the classic it's the
classic
uh crime scene right and um i don't know
if you want to talk to that really but i
but i really like that one line where
where the drowning is in the deed which
i really feel some um something i'm
trying to get to like i'm looking at the
things in the house and the house itself
is a problem with the things and so i
don't know what anyone's thought about
yeah and rodney i was also struck i was
struck very much by that line and the
only a butcher knows if bones had a good
body
um and then in some ways
you know perhaps again
reminding me of sonia a little bit the
you know we we know
i think he said we knew murder was laid
into the house
so all of these seem to be kind of like
i don't know
things that occurred to me in the same
way they did to sonia but i want to
throw this open also because you're also
up if you want to be
i didn't know if cool was going to say
something
sound is off
no i i was waiting for you um
yeah um okay i'll go then
uh
yeah i'm not
i mean i guess one of the the primary
concerns in in this at least this set of
poems is
um you know
telling i guess or uncovering a voice or
a narrative that sort of has been
obfuscated in some way or uh has
disappeared
and
you know i i guess there's an attempted
recovery in some of these poems i think
uh and you know
you know as sonya mentioned
this idea about
trauma right maybe
there's some things that should be left
unsaid
um
i think if
a lot of the things that we think have
occurred in the past uh you know have
been maybe sugar-coated or dressed up in
a certain way and
uh it's
i think it's important um
to sort of
i guess even if i guess it's worth the
the trauma or the
you know the uh
the
you know the effort of uncovering some
of these um stories that have been sort
of buried
uh or
uh forgotten
and so um i don't think that
you know i was i was um
[Music]
you know i i was cognizant of that right
of like not um doing too much or trying
to do too much in these poems and so i
know if you've noticed but i i don't
typically write in form but a lot of
these poems were in different forms and
formal
um you know traditional forms for
example i use the villanelle
in there because i think that's a way to
sort of
channel some of these maybe some of this
violence into something that's more
manageable
and that the mind can sort of deal with
um so i i typically write in in very
free um free verse
and not in in structured form and so i
think one of the techniques that i used
for
for for these um poems was to was to use
form
um
but yeah i don't know if what i said
just makes any sense it makes any sense
but yeah
[Music]
to be honest i don't remember what the
question was
um
the conversation is just so full
and i'm just you know
um
just processing so
you would have to remind me of what the
question was
why don't you say more about your sense
of being a storyteller and um
maybe there's something to say playing
off what rodney was talking about about
what's revealed and what isn't or how to
think about
trauma how you think about trauma and
your own work and what should remain
unsaid if anything
any of that yeah i don't know if there's
anything that should um remain unsaid
um
i'm just taking it back to trisha's work
that's the reason why maybe
maybe that's the reason why this book
struck me so deeply because
so many of those stories you know were
those that
um kind of aligned with things that i
had heard
these are the things that you don't
um
say out like that that's the stuff that
i'm interested in what's hidden
what's kept like the stuff the china
that that you don't let the company
you know you know what i mean like this
side that other side of the bed like
what's hidden under the bed what's
trapped in the closet like that's the
stuff that
um
that i'm interested in um
it's not easy um it actually from this i
don't know if i'm answering your
question but i wanted to i was thinking
about something that sonya said because
maybe this
all of it um relates but
i'm and even thinking about trauma i'm
wondering she said like headache
heartache
um
i'm wondering you know how do you even
when you're looking at for example like
what's
what's underneath what's hidden you know
what's kept away like what we
sort of reject right what we look down
upon what we shun was consistently
disregarded
which is
pretty much the case of people like me
my people
you know women like the woman in my
story who's my great grandmother who was
uh
who was a maid
right doing domestic work
not able to use the bathroom in the
house but
you know some of them were good enough
to breastfeed
you know um
someone's child for example right
um
so i'm saying
how do we now
for me i'm always thinking about how do
i tell this story how do i let the story
lay into me
without
being harmed
and i wonder then for us as storytellers
because it's so much to hold and so much
space to carve
it's like what do we do for ourselves
what kind of self-care
how do you so it's like i'm i don't know
if i'm even answering the question but i
think actually my question is actually
more important than my answer
which is and i wanted to just direct it
at you sonia because i was
literally blown away like well i don't
even know how i'm sitting here like on
this chair
here and now i'm blown away
by some of by by your work
and i'm one in it and it was
it was hard for me to to hear and to see
right as a part
you know i feel like obviously
particularly tied to a history
herstory
and so i wonder for you how do you
what kind of
you know self-care like how do you sort
of not lose it because i know for me
like just writing that story or just
reading this book
is hard
you know what i mean to like
pull pull myself out of it interface
with reality as a sane human being
you know what i mean so this is kind of
directed at
everyone you know whoever wants to enter
i'm happy i'm happy to take that just to
respond uh quickly i feel
um so they're to be very practical like
so really helpful is to have a studio so
that you have a distance between what
you're doing what
you're making
and um currently i don't have that so
i'm literally living with my work
it makes the work
more personal
um but it's very hard
um
i work collectively in spaces that are
overwhelming for example to enter the
royal geographic society headquarters in
london in
in the map room where all those map
mapers left
um i started a collective called it the
map lecture because i knew it was just
too much for me to do on my own
so working collectively is a strategy
for me
i'm also a member of a collective called
um what the hell she doing when we're um
women from across the about women from
across artificial artists from across
the
african continent and his diasporas and
um
what we have in common is that people
say what the hell is she doing
we um that's the support network that i
have
um and the other thing is um salt bath
lots of bath and salt especially after
going into places with uh ordealing or
handling um
[Music]
these kind of bodies that i feel and
handling after handing that or going
into these spaces some of the spaces
that rodney was talking about how
they're resonant like even like the
paneling like salt baths afterwards
so um
those are the practical ways that i
navigate um this but
very helpful also is to be able to start
um
which
doesn't
can't always happen but that's also very
helpful but i mean of course this
fellowship like this is just
you know an amazing catalyst and
enabling so many other kind of things
those are my um
those are my
those are my strategies really
yeah just to echo some of what sonia
said
uh for me i work um
[Music]
or try to work with other
poets and writers and try to promote
them as much as possible so i work
closely with florescent press which is a
small indie press
in south texas that puts out a lot of
voices from people of color
we publish a lot of poetry and
and fiction
and um so
you know trying to find new voices
uh to put on to the world i think is
important to to help others
you know get their voice out out there
i do pretty much the same kind of work
with with newfound which is a press that
has a little bit uh different uh aim but
is also interested in promoting voices
of color
uh primarily um
and then well i i have a uh i have a
full-time job and so that sort of keeps
me grounded in
in the world i guess and not
get carried into what sometimes can be
very depressing
uh work in
in the research
um
you know because it is it is very
depressing i mean it's there's no way
around that it's just
um and knowing that
you know we're sort of at the at the
knife's edge
in our society in a lot of ways
we could sort of quickly devolve
into into that state of exception that
sort of existed in the past if we aren't
already there in a lot of ways
um but yeah in in my work um it's uh
it's at a university and so i'm helping
students a lot of them first generation
um
students who um you know are sort of
navigating
you know the university and college life
and just trying to make it in the world
and trying to figure themselves out and
um so i think that's that's good because
i i sort of
uh you know i'm putting my energy into
that primarily you know full time uh and
then the poetry serve is something else
that that i do so i think it's important
to be grounded in something where i'm
helping
somebody else get along in the world
cool would you like to talk about the
question yourself that you raised
personally
you know i i don't i'm it's a struggle
in all honesty i mean there are times in
which i've songs that i've written
because i have to do a lot of research
you know what i mean for me to write for
example that song that i've um read or
performed a recital what have you
i had to do a lot of research because i
want to be
accurate um in the telling of this um
account right
um and it's also like talking to people
um
in the family like there's so much um
to learn in the kitchen and
conversations with other women in the
family it passed down
you know even at a funeral you find out
all these other new information you
didn't know about something that changes
everything
so i don't you know
i guess it depends on what it is i mean
there are times in which i've written
things and i couldn't get out of bed for
for days it was that heavy it was that
hard
um but uh community
and it was just kind of like basically
what you know what i heard
is i think that there's so much power
and community in um
um
and being held by folks who understand
where there isn't
much to be explained because it's so
exhausting
but just being held by those who
understand um has really helped me
um
you know
thank you um
one of the other things on my mind as
all of you were talking was the question
of being readers and researchers which i
think i heard in different ways each of
you talk about and i just i don't i
don't i could ask a very specific
question about this but i'd rather just
raise this is something for discussion i
mean sonia you talked about phonon for
example you were just talking about the
research rodney you for example were
talking about amatanza
you know your relationship to that
period or set of events
which of course you would know about
through reading maybe in other ways but
certainly through reading
so
i guess i just wanted to raise this for
discussion if there's anything to say
about how you think about yourself as
readers as researchers why why and what
you read if you want to talk about that
when you stop reading if you don't if
you do
anything along these lines but it came
up i think for in all in all three of
your comments
does anybody want to start
you can also take this in a very
different direction but i'm happy to
start and i i'm really glad that you
raised this because um when at one point
i was someone said to me oh artists
don't read
and i found that so offensive
i
i have a very heavily researched based
practice um and that is a lot of a lot
of texts i
last time i had to move i had 23 boxes
of books
with
um
as but but books are not the only
relevant researchers as a cool saying
like funerals the kitchen those places
are
deep places of learning um
very humbling spaces of learning and so
for me my research based practices is
i mean i'm mining that but i'm also
thinking in terms of um
art history visual history the visual
language of europe um and the visual
language of um
the continent of africa
some of the things that thread through
what is carried through to the caribbean
and then i'm also thinking in terms of
states and here in the europe so
all of those spaces of research some
embodied research like actually going to
a plantation or actually being in a
great house in the caribbean like my
research
i feel like my research practice started
when i was 12 and i was taken to barrett
house which is
one of the
great so-called great houses or other
former plantations in jamaica um and i
was taken there because i was considered
to be too uppity and it was time to show
me where it came from
and so i was standing at age 12 in this
house and that was the beginning of like
dealing with great houses and i feel
like um
that
with that kind of research embodied
research as well as like book based rex
research is like just like if you're
doing both it's really tough it's hard
work but very um
meaningful
so i i um
and i can explain my works always in
terms of research i have to because it's
a very hostile space out there i mean
when i wrote
um when i wrote
um
about the hogarth for tate i had a
really bad pushback this is not a you
know how can you say this is this is a
woman how can you how you know
has it come to this was the cry you know
like um even in the furniture it's
implicated um
so you have to base everything i say
like on prestigious research because
it's
actually
attacking a material culture
um and people don't like that if you're
going to say oh this person is bad they
were a slave owner that's that's not so
bad because that's separate
that's not but if you attack on the
material culture
we're all implicated
or if you're questioning the material
because we're all implicated and that's
really problematic and of all the
comments like many people were invited
to to reconfigure
um
hogarth but mine was singled out
from a for considerable more attack
simply because i was doing that um
yeah so it's it's it's uh it's it's
necessary if you're
doing something that's challenging um i
kind of status quoted to
to be prestigious researcher and i
really thank my first degree um
for that because i was never able to say
anything remotely
woke
uh without backing anything up massively
um
in their spaces
yeah
i'll just jump in and say i became a
writer i think of myself as a lyrical
like a romantic
um
um lyricist within the hip-hop tradition
i became a writer through reading
through being a reader first and
foremost i mean as a little girl i read
phyllis wheatley
langston hughes you know maya angelou
like i mean you know just all of the
greats
right until i started to ask questions i
still read phyllis lutely and langston
hughes but at some point you kind of
become radicalized and then i was
looking for
you know um
some um something to sharpen my sword to
sharpen my oyster knife and started
reading like zoro
and um audrey lord and of course the
brilliant genius bell hooks and uh and
then i discovered this beautiful pool of
black feminist literature to which i'm
still drowning and i don't want to come
up to the surface don't ask me to come
out i'm here okay y'all talking to me at
the bottom at the ocean floor
but when i discovered tony morrison is
when my life just
tony morrison gave me a standard and
you know a light
a chair a window to see out of a window
to jump through you know what i mean
like a world
um but also uh like you said uh reading
writing speaking
listening
uh and i think like um
listening right like seeing recording
looking at what's happening like that's
in my opinion what's what makes one a
good um like if we're talking about
hip-hop like a good mc
you know like you have to have kind of
like the poets are
um
you know the prophets like
so you have to kind of be open to some
extent you're reading every anything to
like make sense
and then to produce
you know
our our compass
um to construct a compass foot for us so
um
yeah
yeah um you know i've written four uh
poetry collections and
it wasn't until this last one this
fourth one that i really
um have a note section where i reference
things that i've read and researched
and i think it's important i guess
uh if if we're writing as i am about
things that actually happened um
historical occurrences that you know if
we want to be authentic and we want to
speak
um truthfully i think it's important to
to read at least those secondary sources
and become familiar with them
you know just if you if you want to be
an ethical i guess an ethical poet it's
necessary for you to do that
um
[Music]
excuse me
and uh
yeah so
there was something else i wanted to say
and i completely forgot um
[Music]
yeah i don't know what i was gonna say
before i have a question for you rodney
about reading um
is there anything to say about your
background in philosophy as a student of
philosophy and its relationship to the
work you do as an artist
yeah excuse me a lot of my work is
actually informed by
looking at the world philosophically i
guess
uh and so
uh i guess in contemporary poetry maybe
shying away from abstraction is is a
common thing but i i don't do that uh
and especially dealing with this kind of
work
um and you know we mentioned before that
it sometimes gets a bit too heavy and
sort of removing yourself through
abstraction i think is one technique
that i think i i use uh and philosophy
comes in in handy there
um
and also i think there's you know
there's this sort of classical clash
between philosophers and poets right
the different ways of approaching the
world but i i think you know um
philosophy is really
uh
important in a lot of ways and like the
way even the like the poetry
that i write at least is is uh
like couched i guess in in the language
because
um i don't
you know i i think if i wanted to do
something else i'd use fiction or prose
or you know
something like that as opposed to using
poetry and so there's something that to
be gained in poetry that i think that
sort of philosophy is a as a technique
illuminates
um and it's looking at
you know emily dickinson's famous line
about looking at the world
uh sort of um
you know uh
shooting i've forgotten that i've
forgotten the quote but looking at it
sort of a scans right not looking at it
directly
and so yeah i mean i think that
if if not uh overtly it's
that influence is there uh in the
background and you probably heard it
working and the poems right i sort of
like to like to write elliptically um
especially dealing with heavy heavy
stuff in this collection
uh and i seem to be yeah i seem to be uh
tiring out sorry about that for getting
my quotes
well we're almost at time i think
sonia were you gonna have something
please i was i was gonna add that um
um
i studied philosophy at st andrews um i
didn't come i didn't major in philosophy
but it was one of my main minor um
things that i studied um obviously
european philosophy and
it struck me how often they were talking
thinking in terms of furniture in terms
of tables and chairs um and how
and and that's really
led me to think about like that feeds
into a lot of my work with performing
furniture this very
space of the philosopher at the table in
the chair and all the labor that goes
into supporting the philosopher that's
not that kind of happens around that
domestic space it's never questioned or
theorized um
i
after graduation i've had the
opportunity to really study african
philosophy and reap large but
philosophies of different parts of
of of africa and it's really informed my
work and some of it has come out only
i've discovered how much is in the work
by um
actively seeking um
relationships with uh with other artists
on the continent who then start to
explain to me this is what this is what
this is so it must be a kind of a
a a blood memory or a
some kind of other memory that i'm
calling on there
um and as aku was talking about
listening
i i didn't talk about this in my
presentation i also have a whole thing
where i talk about how i listen to
furniture so i'm sitting and listening
to the chair like what does the chair
want to do so for example the
gentleman's club chair i've spent many
times listening to that chair and said
it wanted to rest itself
so there's a there's a there's a there's
a deep
uh philosophy of listening to objects
that can uh that is very productive a
very like a driver in my work um and so
sometimes i say i have performative
practices we also have a listening a
listening practice and um
yeah i think that also comes back to a
philosophy of what can speak and what is
allowed to speak and what is considered
dumb
um
that also undermines that kind of
european eurocentric philosophy whereas
other philosophies understand
um that everything has memory and
everything can speak
brilliant
yeah cool i saw you nodding i wondered
yes
she's given me my entire life um you
know with her words roberta flack said
killing me softly um
yes uh it's just it's this it's i i find
it um similar in my own practice just
listening to the character
you know what
you know when the character now um
is able to speak
and you kind of just um
you have to like yield and allow
yourself to be a vessel for what comes
um and sometimes you know
afterwards i might look back at
something i've created and it's like i
wasn't even there you know what i mean
i don't know if um
like there in some spaces there it it's
not really safe to talk in this way
because people kind of think that you're
crazy you know what i mean
but um i do um get what sony is saying
because i do think that there's an
african philosophy where
that's just understood it's it there's
space for it and like there's vocabulary
and like people understand you know that
your channel needs something and that's
just
you know um
um and that's just like what it is
um
yeah
i appreciate that so much and i guess as
a final question and i just wanted to
again raise a raise an issue more than a
specific question but see if it it
prompts you to
to any remarks and that's just something
forward-looking um that you've been
thinking about recently you know rodney
you mentioned the kind of state of
exception and the nice edge that we seem
to be on or in at the moment and there
are so many
um reasons to feel despondency and
paralysis in this moment and i know the
three of you are certainly moving
forward in many ways and you're watching
other people move forward in many ways
so
just wanted to invite you to say
something along those lines whether it's
about something you're excited about
doing that you haven't already talked
about here or something you see other
people doing that's you know giving you
life and
joy or something along those lines right
now it could be a nice way to close if
people want to
want to speak in that spirit i mean
there is a kind of philosophy behind
behind the question which is one that we
need one another and that we need to be
mindful of the good things happening in
the world and take strength in those
things
and so like anyway i would just invite
any um comments or thoughts that you
might might have in that spirit rodney
yeah i i'm really excited about you know
i i
worked with um youth poets as poet
laureate mcallen
and one of the things that we did was we
published an anthology
of uh youth poets from the lower grand
valley in texas and so i'm really
excited about like these younger poets
that are coming up and the wonderful
wonderful work that they're that they're
putting together i think they really
have a strong voice i think a lot of
them are
really uh mindful of uh history and
really trying to um you know they have
the these social justice concerns i
think that are important
uh and so and then they're not only
doing that like on the page but also out
in the world and they're heavily
involved and that's just
so hopeful to me because i i grew up in
a time where poetry was heavily
controlled by a certain type of person
right and so i wasn't welcomed i don't
think into that world and now there's so
much going on where poetry is very
accepting of you know people from
different walks of life and people of
color
and these younger poets i think are
really embracing that and so that fills
me with hope to see where the poetry
world at least that i i know
and love is heading and it's really
growing and becoming more accepting so
[Music]
i'll say that i recently became a mother
and
um
[Music]
it's
um
it's a master class
you know there's so much that i've
learned um that i may have thought of
intellectually but like now that it's
embodied and i'm in the fullness
it's it's a master class i've learned a
lot like just stretched and to expand
and to widen
and the depth of my heart you know what
it means to to love someone um and also
to be
you know to
to be up close to to see
something so pure and you know that kind
of innocence and excitement
um so closely that's so beautiful and
kind of helps me
have hope um
for what's to come
and it's also um i mean it's also left
me very terrified like in all honesty
i've never been more terrif um terrified
in my life you know like i have a little
black boy here this is america like
there's a level of terror that has
descended upon me
but i'm not trying to get into that and
that wasn't the question
um but you know just to now think of a
new vocabulary how to explain the
complexity of the world to a child who's
seeing things for the first time oh look
mango
to to experience that you know the taste
of something sweet for the first time
it's this is really really nice and it
um
it's definitely um
glorious
um
and hopeful things
so
in in terms of art i mean today um uh
the venice brianale opened and
um simon lay and sonia voice
respectively to
women of color opening national
pavilions are
very exciting because uh you know
obviously followed their work
um i think that's that's really
interesting and hopeful
um
in terms of the most pressing
issues of our time which i think are
um
social injustice which is rooted in um
slavery um racism
um and uh the environment which i think
i keep trying to say i think it's just
one this one body this one thing um i
think that there's really interesting
work in terms of reparations not just in
terms of
um finances but recreations in terms of
environmental reparations and putting
land back to what what it was
um
i think that's really
really exciting there are a number of um
groups that are working on that and
that's for me uh like also a hopeful
space
well thank you so much all three of you
i mean i'm just
it's hard not to sound very cliche here
but you know
really appreciate what you've given me
in this conversation and you know i feel
like
just being witness to your commitment to
you how thoughtful how hard working
um you are um
how insightful you are how collaborative
you are in your um you know in your mini
spheres of collaboration um
certainly
um bolsters me i mean i think there's
many reasons to be upset and be worried
and we would be wrong not to be upset
and not to be very worried
but i think the leadership and the
vision that the three of you and others
whom you know and working with
provide is just it's important to me so
thank you all all three of you um
you know
really again i'll just reiterate how
honored we've been to have an
association with you and how grateful we
are to you
um you know how um how closely we'll be
um keeping track of you in in the good
ways
not in the surveillance place in the
good ways um in the years to come and
how eager we are to you know to continue
to support your work so
thank you to the three of you thank you
to our written staff and thank you to
those of you of you here on the call um
who are with us today and um
we wish you you know all good things in
the weeks and months ahead and are
grateful again for your time and sonia i
know you're in a very different time
zone than ours
so it's it's it's it's it's another time
of day or night where you are than it is
for the rest of us so thank you all and
be well and we'll look forward to
staying touched in the future